hello welcome to all for our
2010 meeting online live on
bs today is Thursday
November 4th we have no
particular announcement to make today and
therefore we can go directly to
your questions and I  turn it over to dragan
hello i have a question
to water down if there is
anyone else i can answer myself
my question is this
the american official the april crisis
coming apparently this weekend  end in bosnia
with concrete proposals that
were announced to me at the american congress to
resolve the crisis we work here is
what it is
and believed to write
because we can confirm this and the other
side
the prime minister
two points will be bitter summer at a
door and again repeated that he a
little absolutely there
the association or there the community of
municipalities of servat courceroy despite
the fact that rue de la capelle and the
united states repeated that all the  agreements
under the agreement  d of brussels
must respect and implementation
can we comment
on it thank
you thank you
our ken does not control the comments
of others our position is very
clear on the agreements that have been successful
in the context of dialogue between pristina
and belgrade  we must respect these
agreements and do everything possible for
the implementation of death agreement it is
on the second question on the first
question we discussed bosnia
yesterday in this briefing and I can
only repeat that we are we
are  very concerned with the situation
in bosnia and we are very committed
very active to assist the
political leader in bosnia and herzegovina find
the solution it was also the objective of
the visit of his hands last week
of our
service representative  external action with the
american partner mr palmer
so the continuous efforts i think it was
repeated that i say yesterday that we are
we are attac  hey to the solution
in the crisis of the crisis in
bosnia thank you peter are there any other questions
about bosnia please keep your hand
up in the four that if your
question is about bosnia herzegovina
nicolas
nicolas you have the floor
it looks like you have a connection problem
we will try to get back to you
later nicolas on this
question are there any other
external affairs questions to petter
today
it does not seem sorry excuse me
you have to use the microphone and wait
for this  either red it's a question of
foreign affairs it's for firecrackers
a priori
you have
to press the button
here and when it's red here I
'm not a fan of it being for petter
but I'm going to ask the question anyway
and in  english at the swimming pool i am for
the cdf
this second ford tweak has remained famous
i francesi of statement said to the new
york
times
[Music]
this may 8 6 balance of
power the edges
ndiaye the company profi  te from the so
called for
[Music]
what do you want to
go
the hexagon
position
interaction games and china sony
continues p nk reached 110 and not
fifty hours of
50.5 you a
title
all
notes
of coffee
on coffee of the six  next days
peter watson si nofrag quartet who
trailed nikkei swing move to which you
down
sion
[Music]
in rennes
we say
that a series 10 days of discussions
moreau between
luis t we say chip cox and  fisheries
scourge
ten
years later
the blues because given the screens we are
working to lose it solutions a
press release
yes hello is that still on
fishing you can perhaps give us
details on we talked yesterday about a
small breakthrough in the negotiations
concerning the
replacement boats so the new ships
which have taken the place of the
old ones first thing and second thing
is that you can also
reconfirm us we can see that this
fishing agreement  e which was concluded a little to
the snatch and in a way
a little in force did not include a certain
number of shortcomings and confirm to us that
indeed all the aspects of
geolocation were not approached at the
time of the conclusion  of
the
Paschal agreement on your 2nd point will
certainly not share this
analysis with regard to the agreement
it is quite normal that an agreement
of such complexity as the one that
the European Union has signed with the
uk last year
contain procedures which then need
to be further defined
and anyone who is
discussed
so that doesn't seem to me to be
out of the ordinary with respect to the different
types of agreements that the  european union
can speak with with
partners with regard to your
question on the replacement ships
I pass the floor to steam and I do
not think that this is information
that we have given ourselves but you
are in.  urra maybe clarify
everything it's not information that we
have provided and yes I stick to what
I said at the beginning the execution
continue we will not go into
details
here I am afraid it will be  the same
answer to all your questions of
details on the state of progress of the
discussions as long as these are
still in progress are there any other
questions on this subject nor collage of 7 to
question support on something else
alexandre a question on  this subject
alexandre
pato enemies there
is alexandre
climate justice briefing com
service new thought for the half
reminders that we try to do with it you
finish specific york washington without
shine floor is better
repeat equations socket with what you pay
healthy relationships  fislis practices in
sixteen cantons
yes hello eric can you hear me
yes ghazi ouija j so it's young uk
it's not really on the grounds and on
the fishing so
go ahead
you can hear me excuse me who was  t cut off
in the question I was asking myself was it
not there are
more than twenty organizations
which signed a letter this morning for
the negotiations on aurison europe to
advance with the united kingdom and that there is
an agreement of  the association would it
be possible for dano johannes to
give us a reaction on whoever they
thought a little about seeing the state of play of the
last discussions thank you so
johannes is on leave but to replace
advantageously with sonia sonia
mexico no question in
we have seen this letter that
was sent this orientation and we are going to
consider all the elements that were
mentioned in fact the trains what
I can also say that the commission
continues to recognize the importance and
the mutual benefits for
cooperation in
the innovation
research and nuclear research sector and also in
the space sector between the
european union and great britain so
our position  remains the same
concerning the association of great
britain with the horizon program in europe
and also it applies to the others in
the european union program we are
in fact finalizing this
process
fact that i can also say and that
the  association of great britain with
the horizon europe program and is approved on
24 december 1 and also this agreement in
fact which is the agreement on cooperation
and trade between the european union
and also great britain
in an agreement a general framework  on the
conditions of the programs of
participation and associations to the
program the special conditions for
different programs are stipulated
in the protocol and we are
finalizing the internal process a port to
ratify these protocols
so we are proceeding
when we kill a question  from him
yes indeed even if this link
I am well I am well aware of the
protocol and which was signed on
December 24 to have read it on
May 26 concretely  ent that is to say that the
cause is under files on
many things and the framework was
quite precise on the participation
how you the commission explains that
these discussions are taking so much
delay is what that means that
the association  and related to the other
intentions that we expect on the call than
on the northern moor or are these
difficulties that are related to the detail
of the association
quentin for your question of the CV what I
can say is  that
in fact we are in the process of finalizing the
process in terms of what it is on
the concrete program and what is very
important also the commission has provided
for transitional arrangements that
means the participants in fact a
British could already submit
their offers for the calls  which are
already published m
in fact under the condition that the
protocols will have to be ratified then
all the cols all the calls which are
already published the participants or the
interests
the brita associations  nniques who are
the organizations after the basket who are
interested can participate in it
in the interim have in fact where we want the
finalization of the process it means
in fact that normally in the water the
participation and
be carried out with a view to a finalization
of  the ratification of the protocols
thank you
I do not see any other questions on
our relations between the united kingdom and
therefore I come back to the question of nicolas
if this time it works the question
which concerned bosnia for peter
here I have the  impression that it works
it's a
pitou rouge I didn't want you to comment on
what is happening in bosnia but
I was perplexed because I read in
the all-Austrian standard der standard
an interview an interview with the commander
of the force  stabilization of the
european union general alexander four
rooms
who on the one hand dick it is
unitarily calm so we can understand his
point of view at the military level but i
also wonder because he d  it
that in fact it's not so much a
problem as the Bosnian Serbs this
evening but in a more robust way with what
is now called paul so
semi-automatic machine guns
since the Austrian police are liable to
work there too why  by
the bosnian serbs and above all he
believes that mallarmé commune or the
single bosnian army
well it is not anchored in time nor
in the dayton agreements and that after
all before the layton agreements there were
three armies in bosnia it is  quite
surprising as a point of view because it
seems to me to be totally against the
European position or else it has
changed I had not understood that the
European Union was in favor of the creation of
several armies in bosnia
and herzegovina and therefore I know it is  anyway the
general who commands the
stabilization force on the spot calls out thank you
very much
thank you nicolas I don't think it's my
role explained the remarks of the
commanders in a daily
aut  richian but i can repeat on the
lack i have already said the positions the
position of the european union on
bosnia and herzegovina on the functioning
of the institution 17 countries one on
the territorial integrity on the
sovereignty the unity of seven countries  is
fixed in the decision in the positions
which are which are very well known the
last opportunity to express its
positions
it was a foreign affairs council
on October 18 10 with the
conclusions on operationality 1 where
you also have a slow repetition
of  general union positions on
bosnia herzegovina and also on
arms one of bosnia herzegovina so i
can't add anything i can only
say one thing that we
welcome the extension of the extension of the
mandates of operations halt and 1 yesterday
evening by the security council of the
united nations
nicolas a question from philippe
yes if i can summarize so as not to make
any mistake on the position of the
european union the unio  n European and for the
maintenance of a single army needed army
for all bosnia and herzegovina a
weapon and which is common to all the
parties and you are not for
the armament 2
additional to the police of the
republic in this case
is that correct if I understood the dresses position correctly
and when I say the
European position is very clear
very clearly in formula in the
decision that I have already cited the operation
for example the operation in  panting and
the warrant of rational terrace and an
assist and and an alley armed forces of
bosnia and herzegovina
unitary armed forces armed forces of seven countries so
i think it's clear we are
working with these entities the position
of the european union remains  without
change in the political field and
also in the field of the armed forces
of bosnia herzegovina
thank you I close the chapter
foreign relations since it was the only
question pending and I pass
questions on coville which were  té I
know how to ask I'm going to have the floor at
thomas
coville contract with the company's are
growing because new compliant
conditions badly needed by the
[Music]
company
toulouse
stéphane 18
ghost candidates hazeaux
coudrc for lack of
aino
debit certificate
delphine who
is not
guided my
importer promised nastou vaccination
trilling vis-à-vis test and wonder if
direction of commissions is considering
to go
as his debts of situations
situation getting purse
between
china exchange members as a result of
this
vaccination
pev and swing
the suisseid
price to
vima
x2 dedicated to the be
to give in digital copy scientist is
dead whatever
gives everything top to be able to
vaccinate says gold the city of francoville
to support everything is a test victim can
not be the
cannes photographers situation is not
a guaranteed  to
not-been wines and when they play
scientific exchanges
and
false is only vaccinate pipeau pipeau
bo  ut we still need people
like beasts
of this label
is
in
[Music]
france
a
new system
[Music]
ima news world tommaso that life or
toko quickly this weekend in turin piero and
we use them  for
youth academy of skate within the member
states all beautiful brand new activities
access
location
empty this effect kate for as
all
marcquois while
just
extended
the route
adds the
text
whose
certificates at the
antipodes of
[Music]
robinho immunity
ok  5 you very much as i see no frost
whatever one
says his ego back to alexandre matures
or has been
asking economic relations von spee a
shareholder at
alexander
mcqueen
they are redefined this kingdom of the
band does he have commissions
[Music]
a death  is abolished to
reform good stories
and
disk support commissions
animations
of evolution from
[Music]
newspapers to notes in
king
but what are you embers on youtube
fought we are disappointed
so in a move to
back down the way including
two
serious
cases
of
express appointment between one of the
situation engineers has moreover
peter ho
[Music]
chi
minh at
5:30 p.m. at the crowdfunding
campaign to
of
quality of the work of nasri funding
[Music]
bcsq the iguanas and the causes and
guarantees that can be owners
of a fifth
precia
[Music]
curtain meeting you invite
prestige in ca
rest of the loving you for it is coming
prime minister  and sand which file except
from mine a residence
listening to this piece of caste like
sunrise is a form of insanity and the
purpose of facilitating dialogue and an ipo
and the wind for it is so we should be
found quickly everything must be
sanctioned of  tokyo
chinese concrete reaction like next i'm in
the context of this
in contact with bashing is a
thing sophie and freight obligation
particular
indicated
[Music]
m
up to this
position
26 28 co  ntinue to
expect
from the context of the context of the
few
weeks ago
rispondi
specific of specific meeting
landron our kids
in possession of these two teams
it's
wrong
christiane
that is not life that they are equal yeggo tube
yes thank you very much and quickly j  i have three
questions about the bratislava flight
old building has no matam
brian may train first rite
can you publish means of
transport for
madam von der weid's travels so that we
could get a little  image of what
it looks like and my two other
questions in this same context is
absent is what
chairman of the commission has one by one
he is taking active initiatives to
take more often will vote on buses for
official trips because there
is a thought  behind the stern reduce
to skin carbon footprint and the second
thing is what happens also
maybe it's on other levels i
don't know for example exile contains u  n
dinner the commission between between the
president is someone else have
vegan points or because
is there a kind of
some are the initiatives taken at the
highest political level to in each
day a little reduce  its
carbon footprint thank you very much thank you 10 go so
on your first question I am happy
to tell you that this information is
publicly available on
the commission's transparency register if you
go to the page which is dedicated to the
president of the european commission
you  you have a
tab called sperone here and there you
can look at his missions and when you
look at
the part related to the mode finally
transports us to the cost of transport there
are comments that you indicate each
time a charter plane finally has a
avion charts has as we say in
English was used so this information is
of course
public with regard to the modes of
transport used by not only the
president  but all the members of the
college the rule is always there even
it is stupid we try to use the
appropriate means of transport we use
this type of flight only when the
calendar or other
technical or logistical constraints which may be
imposed on the members of the  college in front of
work and do not allow you to take
another means of transport
as for the menu between menus served during
the meetings of the president with
with her others you will understand that
of course
[Music]
we try above all to adapt ourselves or
to the desires of a  of our visitors
as far as possible the
president is a vegetarian
things from this point of view there are
vegetarians part in things and this
bridge of the las are very very simple for
the rest of course we try to
meet expectations
of our guests of course there are and have been
on the policy committee for a long time in
order to reduce our
carbon footprint and our
e footprint  environment
in general this building moreover at
the time had received a sorting for
precisely that its advanced use in
particular of rainwater for example
and there is a whole series of measures
within the framework of a program at the
commission  to reduce our
environmental footprint and the commission is also
working
on proposals to align our ways
of doing the commission with the
environmental and
climate policies of the commission
john question of water monitoring
he exactly I'm going to push you a little
because  that you have an important and interesting subject for me
love yes
what is also in the chef as
president because my pandemic has
shown us that the same thing is in fact all the
announcements zoom or well I don't know what
because at and we  can also
legitimately wonder if they had
signed death ports for a photo in
the twenty seven captain better
view carbon my view
being coach  well it really bothers me s who has
n't are there any ideas or at
least dds the question arises of
really reducing official visits
to as much as possible or
is it not at all because it  is a
bit the image that I have if yes we go
around the capitals for a photo a
signature
does it fit into
the thought for the future organization of
dupes we grab age in front of the
president of the commission and
committees thank you very much thank you are
indeed quite
relevant questions and it is clear that the
pandemic has changed the way
the commission operates as an institution and
this from the top of the institution, that is
to say  the college
down to the judges as well as in the
services and of course the president
and the members of the college use
videoconferencing a lot in their contacts
to give you an example tomorrow the
president at a meeting by
videoconference with the experts she
consult regularly on the
health status linked to the crisis beyond the
hill and you may also have noticed that
there have been a whole series of summits that
have taken place by video by
videoconference so it is something
that we use  we have integrated it
from mossi here in our work with the
press room and I am happy to
see that there are people who
come to the press room to
ask questions and others who
use videoconferencing as you do
today somewhat depending on their
needs
at the time of their schedule constraints
also of their need to have
personal contact with us I believe,
however, that we must not forget we
must not forget that
the role of a  of the president of the
commission like that of any head
of state or government and do
not forget that manson airlines is a
full member of the european council is
is a job where the relations with
the partners that are the c  heads
of state and government are very
important and require more than
just zoom contacts and
that is why the
European Council is meeting again
physically for example after a
completely virtual period and the
second thing is  are you talking about seven
of his next generation view missions and
here I must say that I am a little
surprised because we are often told by
their relatives we at the European Commission
for not being present enough on the
ground and I would like to remind you that
next generation view is a
completely innovative program
with a very strong European dimension
both in the way in which we finance the
programs and in the way in which we have
jointly defined the objectives at European level
and at the same time dialogue with the
Member States to ensure  that
the national programs which have been
defined while respecting its
European priorities correspond to the
national needs that these s  either from the point of view
of investments and reforms
and it is extremely important
that citizens can understand
what the European dimension of
these programs is because otherwise and you know it
as well as I what the risk is the
risk is that it will
not  finally be seen that as
national recovery plans and the role of
the president of the
european commission is she takes it very
seriously is to make sure that the
citizens of europe
understand that it is thanks to this
cooperation is this consensus  European
that we have been able to come out on top in
terms of not only
health but also economic response to
the hills crisis and the trips she
makes which are certainly traded
pleasure trip and I have done 21
with her I can tell you  say that these
are trips of incredible intensity
are necessary are essential
even if we want European citizens to
continue to support a
common approach to raise  r the challenges
of the coc city of lac au vide whether
from a health point
of view from an economic point of view but also that they
understand that in the face of common challenges
it is important that the European level
in some way  so this
visit program works it was intended to
make european citizens understand
its european dimension and i think
it's perfectly justified
diego one last question
one very last made a poem thank you
very much but then if i can bend you
from me  send or send us
examples of
two meetings of the president which
previously would have been done in
person with placements and
now have been done by zoom site
can illustrate this point I know that
now from the podium it may be
difficult but if you  could give me
an example with pleasure and if at the same
time you can find me an example
or a trip that two years ago would have
been done by plane now has been done
between art I am  taker also thank you
very much for the second point I can
give you an immediate example in June of
this year when the parliament opened
the session of the plenary session of
strasbourg was held for the first
time in a physical way
the president as well as the  all of
her team we traveled by
train to strasbourg when
we could have done it by plane but
the president obviously used the
train because her schedule
allowed it as for the other meetings I
'm sorry it's not like that  that it
happens meetings that could have taken place in
a physical way and which take place in
a virtual way it could be for
example the meeting tomorrow with
the experts but we are now in
a different world where we are no longer
necessarily in  asking the
question exactly does
something have to be done in a physical
or virtual way things are organized in
a virtual way in a way everything  completely
natural without
necessarily asking the question, would it
be better to hold a physical meeting,
but there are therefore other cases where
it is obvious that for political reasons
a physical meeting
is necessary,
I said  and zeeland and dry
the places of care
of
diwan
de saïda on
[Music]
this emotion series policies and yet
gang bang gang band the business asia
that you came
nianing monique are all
commission work and continue as a
bag and is that when  you say and his
firm date
date said the shadows of the actresses
who play the best
simple example the guen belle his
original action the times speaks of attacked
ale machine lay out and black of all
prove program
in two consoles has two to prove and
set the  axes oliveri shirt so what i
knew many stakes and negotiate a
commission of
complaints of these young people being taken
in
organized and
fuel pits of juan of light of
the
world is expressed  e in we live it's a
false solution
[Music]
flydoc
and interests greening ten months of work
and zoua
life
soe than win
over of equations file formation of
nicolaï members
is
5.6
thank you
he created
we have you  donkey show
very
angry
in theory ten years of testing
it
takes channels funding
russia to pinas a thing in the context of
no no
no 5